hello everyone and sorry about no videos
for the past day or two I was at a
wedding and then today after we had a
get-together and it was well it took a
lot of my time and then when I got back
home I was watching the leech a side old
arena so I really didn't have time to do
it I mean I could have done it but I
didn't feel like doing any video so I
thought best not to do it if I don't
feel like it but that's why we're gonna
do at least two videos today so this is
a one-game from the leeches titled arena
I really enjoyed some of you have
requested it already as it really is a
fine showing by both players here a
Carlson doctor Nick Turse tiny faces
turkey's grandmaster 21 year old
grandmaster waha personal and it's
really a wonderful game so let's just
dive straight into it and see what
happens so Carson would the white pieces
opens with the g4 we have the grub black
replies with E 5 and here
d4 just attacking the center with each
capture son d4 and now Knight to f3
there's no Russian in capturing the pawn
and here c5 there is ad there actually
is one game in the database for Bishop
to b4 was played but here c5 is a new
move and interestingly as we move three
already we have a completely new game so
Crossan continues attacking the center a
nice flank attack with c3 we have D
captures and Knight captures so here
Carson is down upon but he already has
two pieces out it's a nice trade off we
have d6 by black and now g5 not even
going for more development cousin
prevents this Knight from developing he
can go to f6 or to h6 and if he goes to
e7 well then the bishop will be have a
pretty hard time getting out so here
black has to figure out how to develop
first we have Knight to c6 across and
strengthens the g5 pawn we have h4 and
now Knight to G to e7 this Knight is now
coming to f5 and only then will the
bishop be developed to e7 and black ball
castle with Bishop to g2 and now nice to
a5 yeah we're not gonna overanalyze
anything as this is a bullet game but
the positions that come up in this game
are so interesting that I just had to
show it and it you know we're just gonna
use it as target practice for your
tactics following you know prowess so
much up to f4 carson develops putting
pressure on the d6 pawn with Bishop d7
black there's the castle and now III
before cross and decides where he's
going with the king he is taking away
the d4 square from the Black Knight
we have castles by black and now even a3
taking more important squares from black
before deciding where to go with the
King Bishop to e6 by black and now Queen
to c2 a very nice area because here
black could have some Knight a5 to beat
three ideas or even Bishop to b3 could
be an idea but here with Queen to c2
cross and solves all of his problems
because now any Knight a5 followed by
Bishop to b3 you can't do that because
the bishop has to keep an eye on the
knight on f5 so d5 by black preparing d4
and here cousin just plays a ruby d1
still not doing anything with the king
with d4 attacking the knight and
preparing to open lines of course not
now as the Queen is still on the D file
cousin just castles as there is no
danger of any captures and now Queen to
see it getting the Queen out of the way
and now well B captures and c3 is a
threat we have E for my cousin and now
of course it's a bullet again we don't
have a lot of time to calculate all of
the captures so black just decided to
capture even though Knight captures an
h4 was an opportunity to grab yet
another pawn as this this threat still
exists here I broke a black decided to
trade off we have D captures pawn
captures on a5 Bishop captures an f5
across since Queen night sorry Sun on
screen nicely defends the bishop on f5
with Queen captures on c3 and now Bishop
to h3 hoping to get some trades here but
cousin not interested he goes in 95 with
the ship captures and g2 King captures
and g2 Knight captures an e5 Bishop
captures and Queen to g4 check here
across and just blocks with the bishop
as you also have to defend the h4 pawn
you could also block with the Queen but
cousin prefers to keep the Queen on the
board for now and here while you could
start bringing your other pieces into
the game here with Queen to b4 check and
here across and now offers the Queen
trade with Queen to f3 and now Queen
captures with King captures and now well
across and still doesn't have any great
compensation for the pawn black is up a
pawn
and Carlson is a little bit better on
time although one could argue in bullet
a little bit better on time is much
better on time but still it's hard to
justify at this point here but you know
this is bullet we're in for the fun so
why not just enjoy it
rook 88 seems like the way to go but
Sanel goes for Luke after dat creates
space on f8 for his King as he will have
to defend the bishop cross and doesn't
want to trade as he's down upon we have
rook to e1 attacking the bishop and now
King to f8 rook to e4 now gaining a lot
of activity on the on the four track row
and now comes a rook to e1 doubling up
on the e-file is the idea rook the d3
black wants to do the same he wants to
double up on the D file with came to g4
and now rook a to d8 nicely doubling up
on the D file and Bishop to e5 now cross
and transfers the bishop and is much
more useful diagonal but also the bishop
will be guarding the B to pawn with f6
pushing the bishop back Bishop to c3 and
now rook 8 the d5 with a triple attack
against this g5 pawn here so of course
it has to do something about it first
rook to F for painting the pawn as the
king is on f8 black is unable to capture
and now here if this was a classical
game or even a rapid or blitz black
would probably continue you know just
playing on the Queen side enjoying his
extra pawn but it's bullet here black
decides to go for something special with
h5 with check asking Carlsen do you want
to mess up your pawn structure by
playing G captures on h6 sample son or
do you wanna play capture with the King
and then maybe compromise the safety of
your King cross and says I'm not I'm not
afraid of this with King captures on h5
and now King to f7 and here rook to e1
just putting pressure on the e-file
and here you have to be very careful
what you do because here rook to e1
pretty much loses the game for for
cousin but it's a bullet game and it's a
really hard move to spot but you know
you're at home it's a nice Sunday you're
enjoying yourself watching this nice
video feel free to pause the video and
try to find the idea
sun'll missed in this position it's a
very nice idea well I have a nice sip of
my water
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
solver of tactics on a Sunday and for
this week we just wanna enjoy the show
Bishop to d6 it's more of a just get
your Bishop out of e7 so how white that
doesn't have this nasty capture but also
your attacking the rook and here white
will just have to give up the rook if
you move the rook let's say rook rook F
e4 then you get g6 and then you're in
trouble
because if you go to g4 now due to the
bishop controlling this diagonal here in
the rook controlling the third-ranked f5
is checkmate so this is one problem and
if you don't go if you go up the board
King h8 then you get rook captures on g5
a very nasty idea and you don't really
have anything to do here you can I mean
rook h5 will be made so you can just
capture and then rook each three leads
the mate
rook age four captures again is
checkmate so here's a not missed a great
opportunity to punish Magnus for his you
know have play with with the overactive
King and this rook e1 but he didn't he
played g6 seemingly the idea is the same
but it's not
King h7 by Carson and now the problem is
if you go rook g5 like in the line we've
shown now Magnus has rook captures on e7
you just get the King out of the way and
then real captures and f6 will pick up
the rook here whatever you play King e6
captures here and you're just down down
a piece also everything is nicely
protected so white will be completely
winning here so it's similar but not
quite the same after crossing sking h6
with Bishop to f8 check getting the
bishop out of the way with check it
seems like everything is going you know
according to plan
King to h7 and now again you don't have
the option of doing any sneaky tactics
like this because then Carson has rotate
captures on f6 and now this is checkmate
as the rook controls this line and the
King prevents the black King from moving
of course so even though you got your
bishop out of the way with check you
don't really have any any defense left
on your f6 bone so here with f5 by black
and now cross in place h5 now it's
cousin who's who threatens made H
capture Sanji's
sex will be checkmate as again now the
white king is preventing the black king
again and the rook is still controlling
the e-file so rook to H rook to H sorry
rook to h3 the only move black has now
the pony spin of course you cannot
capture with h6 by Magnus and here again
if this was some normal game black would
play b5 continue playing on the Queen
side but here black wants the finish
finish Magnus we have rook to these
seven now preparing some nasty ideas and
you have to be very careful so what do
you do here
if Carsten played a slow move like
Bishop to f6 then a black threat was
Bishop captures an h6 this was the idea
and after G capture skin captures an f6
and there's nothing more for white to do
here it's checked the discover check
from the rook you have to move the King
now get the rook da check King has to
move back and now rook captures on h6
this was the plan King captures rook to
h8 will be made of course the King box a
white King's retreat to any square so
this was blacks plan but cross and of
course after up to d7 doesn't play a
slow move in fact Magnus finishes the
game as now White has a winning idea so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this nice winning idea photos we
were able to do it congratulations on
finding the mate into on this lovely
Sunday and for those you who just wanna
enjoy a show now its rook captures on f5
this is what Magnus played and this ends
the game the black King still can't go
anywhere rook controls here Mitchell
controls this diagonal King controls g8
so your only move is to capture the pawn
which is what black did and now of
course comes g6 black King has no
squares and of course it's checkmate
so really a wonderful wonderful game by
both of them and I don't we don't over
analyze bullet games but you know the
positions that arise are so interesting
we can use them as as target practice is
so to say and one more interesting fact
by winning this title the arena cross
and is now in 2019 undefeated in every
tournament that he played in classical
time format but also in bullet time
format so he won't
Skol tournaments he played and all
bullet tournaments and here are the
standings of the elitist titled arena
again it was a race between Magnus and
Andrew tank also known as as the penguin
so Magnus first place penguin second
place and GM cashing third place I have
no idea who that is if you do know share
in the comments
Magnus finished with a performance of
3049 that is very impressive with a win
rate of 75% and he went berserk some of
the games penguin with a performance
20:29 51 with 64 percent rate and 10%
berserk rate and we have GM caching with
2805 and then we have some some of the
other guys GM Hawaiian Ted I don't know
who most of them are as every title
arena there are more and more
grandmasters applying GM wizard 98
international master boss 100 5 the
chess bros also not sure which was but -
due to the high rankings probably Eric
then we have e M theory are - then a lot
like Fredrik and then GM TGK 59 so those
were the standings and I do hope you
enjoyed the game like I said we're gonna
have at least one more video today
finishing up a couple Blancas match with
Bora caustic so prepare for that and I
would like to thank rich Piper johanna
cliff and nicholas padam paul jacobs and
derek bocal hide that for a conversion
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content so that's pretty much it thank
you all I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your Sunday